well I think the movie was somewhat
misleading in this regard in fact the
hospital had been opened in 1919 1924
the first victims of what was then an
epidemic sweeping across the world and
some of them had been there for for 40
years or more although when I walked in
and I i saw these motionless speechless
transfixed figures sometimes in very
strange postures this was completely
outside my experience or imagination I
had never seen anything like this in a
sense these fossilized human beings at
that time there was no medical approach
which was of any use to them although it
had always been observed that they could
move sometimes and speak under special
circumstances and among these was was
when music was present